happening on the board the English  opening maybe you're not a bus here in  the studio but this last move uh major  chocolate Lawrence D3 I think  griststroke was the one who uh  popularized it a few years ago I think  kramnik also had a few outings with this  a few years back it's a very  um it's it's a move which says to Black  you've got lots of options here but I  want a non-theoretical battle and I just  want to get a position that's playable  against you so it's quite an interesting  approach  um  and something I don't recall Vincent  doing previously actually he has that or  has he yeah he has it but uh just uh  only last month September the Sabbath he  beat Nils grandelius with this variation  what was that in was that in and over  the board tournament or it was and the  Polish extra Liga this is the tournament  where Vincent had a tremendous score  and uh and where he reached 2700